[Music]  also tonight A distraught mother is  hoping a precious item is found and  returned while visiting enchant over at  Resorts World she lost a necklace with a  charm on it but it was dedicated to her  son that he was killed by a drunk driver  two years ago she says they came to  Vegas to visit family for Thanksgiving  and to celebrate what would have been  her son's 23rd birthday when I seen the  lights and how beautiful they are I went  to touch his fingerprint and that is  when I seen that the necklace was gone I  really think that it broke off because  there was a little piece of the chain  on my shirt  so you heard that it had her son's  fingerprint on it Wendy reached out and  hoped someone may have found it and is  trying to get maybe trying to find her  get it back to the rightful owner she  says it would be a Christmas miracle to  be reunited with that necklace